what's up guys we are confident today
we're playing a match to 21 points and
after each point we'll be adding one
piece of clothing this is gonna get
sweaty good luck good luck
[Applause]
we've chosen the hottest day of finnish
summer to film this video
if you don't sweat enough in normal
table tennis this will get you sweaty
alright so the first item the brand new
sensei t-shirt i'm looking forward to
putting this on
yes double shots i don't think i've ever
done this before didn't say you still
have cool
down here
making the sensei move for a change i'm
not feeling too happy about putting more
clothes on
next point i'm going to lose on purpose
[Applause]
no i don't want to win the point but yes
it's a punk finsy bandana i can get this
often where can you get this
pongfinity.store ah get out get out of
prong fancy bandana
oh no i missed you get to put some
clothes on
i'll put my favorite sensation purple
one that looks very nice my favorite
color
you can get yours from fanshawe.com
oh no this is this is the worst i hope
you guys are more excited to put this on
when you get it from our store
than what i am to put it on now this is
where the
night messed up but the design
is very cool
backstick is working perfectly
[Applause]
i don't know what i'm doing second pair
of shorts
[Music]
no problem
three t-shirts on
now he wasn't trying to get it on he
just wanted to slap me
my favorite t-shirt who remembers this
comment which video this t-shirt has
been used
make a favorite shot the t-shirt works
actually it's got the breathing hole
looking good now that i have warmed up
i can start doing the footwork let's see
that
i couldn't take it seriously he looks
like he's in a gang or something
it's a big side from here but
this one's gonna be fun my favorite
underpants
what are you laughing about you've got a
problem with my outfit
no no i don't
time for some more merch this is turning
out to be a great advert
for our clothing pongfinity cap it suits
you at this angle
especially this one yeah me got
new summer look
yeah summer 2021 this is the look to go
for
that's why you never play with a cap on
i think that's
for me
look at him i wouldn't want to face
octolife on a dark street
oh the underpants
he's not so scary anymore but again like
in a weird way it actually like suits
you
oh yeah thank you oh actually
this is going to ruin my fashion look oh
you look like a baseball baseball player
the backhand flip's going well today
scared to serve anything now
throw it back to the sumo suit video
feel the same
[Music]
sorry my favorite one
[Music]
oh my god i can't see anything okay if
my footwork isn't fast now then
it'll never be fast
i can't see the ball okay let's even
it's out
enough of showing off the glasses off
but i'm getting a bit hot you want to
put some more clothes on i'd gladly put
some more clothes on
how can i miss that around the neck
glasses are on the net mission
i see like a digital screen okay
now buy them from
maybe in 20 years
oh now you're matching like brothers
hmm nice purple thigh as well otter do
you want to come inside for me
i feel like i'm going to a big event
suiting up very weird christmas party a
very weird christmas time
i don't know who would organize this
sort of christmas party
[Applause]
oh no this is where it gets bad i mean
my legs are already soaking wet
this is my least favorite item so far
see the sweaters
[Music]
i wanted to make him pull and lose
almost the same
color i mean look it has to be matching
clothing
just remember otto we haven't even got
to the winter jackets yet oh no
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
double hat time
i don't want to loop
unless you give me a oh let's give it a
spot i'd like
the next item will be like a
refrigerator or something
oh the scarf is loose
oh no good job look thanks ah yes
it doesn't look very breathable they're
like really colorful
yeah i've got everything
sorry it's getting warm enough i'll
actually close the jacket
i'll do that too because too many things
swinging around
yeah no it's better never been this hot
in my whole life
sorry all that work for nothing
look at this trick shot
okay that's gonna make it hard you look
like you're prepared for like the
harshest winter season
ah
only backhand block from now on nothing
else yeah
looking forward to these that's getting
a bit cold in the hands
what a shot i can look at this sweat
dripping on my
upper lip
not so fun anymore
how was this supposed to i'll put it on
you get your playing position i'll i'll
dress it up for you
i don't trust you i'll tuck it in here
he's got like a tail
coming up
it feels a bit dangerous maybe you put
it like on your
uh waist yeah you tied his
legs that was on purpose
i don't want to put another jacket on no
problem it's just a motorcycle jacket
pretty much finally it's over
and the new sensei collection with this
really cool design
is now available at fanjoylink below go
get yours from there